welcome back to new rock stars marvel's
eternals final nail in the coffin of
apocalyptic events this movie thrusts
upon us is a voice from the shadows
revealed to be
mahershala ali as blade in the mcu how
will this day walker team up with dane
whitman black knight in the mcu next and
could it be in the upcoming moon night
series starring oscar isaac are we
looking at
knights assemble ladies and gentlemen
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we
love i'm eric voss and going rogue with
me today is our very own day walker
jessica clemens i am the knight wait
that's batman
yep i would say wrong cinematic universe
but not according to gilgamesh uh also
joining us today is the host of the
philosopher's podcast and good friend of
the show eddie villanueva what is up
guys i just saw this movie recently and
uh yeah i i got a lot of questions and
uh some things need answering so some
things need answered well that's what we
are here for and what you are here for
you better have some answers ready to go
because we have questions too um and
finally of course the celestial easter
egg hunter extraordinaire it's mt hey
everybody i'm looking for those big
planetary sized eggs always what's going
on
all right let's dive into it folks the
second eternals post-credits scene
revealed dane whitman drawing the cursed
ebony blade and the voice of mahershala
ali as another kind of blade asking are
you sure you're ready for that mr
whitman this would imply a kind of team
up between dane whitman and blade the
vampire hunting half vampire day walker
and a future marvel title the mcu blade
film has been given no release date as
of yet but some believe the two could
reunite sooner than that film like in
secret invasion or in dr strange's
multiverse of madness or even moon
knight a trailer for which we are likely
to see soon you may already have in your
lives by the time you're watching this
video so let's start there the marvel's
apparent reach into this uh supernatural
horror genre with things like vampires
zombies in marvel what if uh demonology
the occult do we think the mcu could be
building a midnight sun's team up or
perhaps organizations like steak or mi13
what do you guys think oh absolutely
like i straight up blade is going to be
the nick fury of the supernatural mcu
this is what they're setting up like
because like you said we are getting
moon night we are um we do know that
agatha harkness is getting our own show
like i think that we're just seeing all
of these players going to be coming
together to to fight a you know this
huge supernatural threat that is on the
horizon fabian mephisto who knows that'd
be a really good one um but yeah i think
that
sprung i said the m word
i'm sorry but no i think that midnight
suns is the more likely scenario here
because it's the one that people keep
tweeting us about constantly uh because
they love it so much midnight sunsets
always so yeah i think that's where
they're headed there but what do you
guys think not
not to mention i mean that would sorry
that would coincide with like the
wreaths of the video game the midnight
suns video game as well coming out uh
so it would be interesting for them to
begin making those treks towards it i
cannot canonically
within the marvel comics we all know
that there's not much history between
the two outside of you know the the team
ups and like mi13 and things of that
sort but right the fact that their
they're retooling some of these
characters and we know marvel is is
known for retooling characters
backstories to better fit their
narrative for moving forward so i i
would i would almost think to seem as
like they would team up to almost try to
catch up with morbius i mean i i would
love to see them do a cameo in in uh and
uh morbius and uh be a part of that uh
uh storyline as well we all know these
are all gonna intertwine at some point
in time so yeah i feel like aside from
the
the uh obvious uh marvel comic issue
where they actually teamed up in mi-13
and then blade had to go because he
tried to kill somebody we we are hoping
that as they continue to move towards
the cosmic aspect as well as the horror
aspect that blade begins to just build
this platform outside of the film so
that way when rehearsal ali finally
shows up on screen there'd be no doubt
at all that it's going to be a badass
showing yeah i think that's um something
to keep in mind that uh they do marvel
studios tend to rearrange team lineups
differently than they were in the comics
i mean back from the the og avengers in
the mcu not exactly what it was in the
comics they didn't introduce wasp until
far later i think they're gonna do the
same with the dark avengers the
thunderbolts they're gonna do the same
with the young avengers they're just
gonna have different young people on
this team who weren't necessarily the
exact young avengers like i don't know
if we're gonna see hulkling in the
mcu um he's great i love it but like
they they they nerf hulk all the time in
the mcu because of vfx like they it's
crazy that they're gonna have ruffalo up
here in she-hulk but i guarantee you
it's gonna be mostly the actor mark
ruffalo not as hulk form because it's so
much vfx budget to animate hulk that way
and for them to do that for for whole
clean for this uh you know not as iconic
character from from the young avengers
comics i think it's it's just gonna be a
while before we see hulk ling and it
wouldn't surprise me if that's just some
budgetary lower priority for the mcu so
all this is just a way of saying that uh
the midnight suns that we see in the mcu
is just gonna have the lineup of whoever
the occult characters are currently in
the mcu i didn't even see agatha
harkness being on this team or like
sylvie or loki being on this team you
know what i mean or it could be just
another long
long game tease again just like they've
done with previous things of like oh
what about this and then seven movies
later and we get what we're talking
about or what about this so it could
very well just be piecemealed to us as
fans but ultimately us who know the the
lore really well and know
what this trajectory looks like more
than most we can kind of assume once we
start seeing the pieces together we can
put that puzzle together and figure it
out ahead of time what do you think
jessica do you think it's um are there
is it gonna be a while before we see
blade and dane whitman kit harrington
show up together is this just some kind
of like punt by the eternal steam to be
like marvel you figure it out whether
it's
down the line or four years ago well i
think marvel has to be aware of what the
post-credit or the mid-credits scene
and credit scene has to be so i feel
like they're aware of it but it would be
very funny if chloe was just like deal
with it
gear take it um i don't really want
another blade movie really bad
i don't care all i care about is blade
that's that was her whole vision i'm
here for it i ultimately uh that's why
i'm so quiet i agree with mt and eddie i
do think i've been uh
manifesting midnight sons for a minute i
want them to all i want to see all of
them we love the scary dark side of um
the marvel universe this could easily
tie in with what ifs marvel zombies they
can bring in so many situations in the
future that i do think this is the
ultimate goal um in like you said boss
they change up teams all the time uh
they change up it doesn't have to follow
the comic books like completely so i
think this is an issue where we're like
yeah instead of putting them on mi 13
for literally like three issues we're
gonna put them in midnight suns um with
these two and then we're gonna get we're
gonna get agatha we're gonna get every
metaphysical we're gonna get more bees
eventually um that's why i think more so
midnight suns would come way farther
down the line because they're still
trying to figure out how we can splice
in morbius because you can't have
morbius and blade in two different well
you can but it's just like he's if we go
with the storyline that he's the one
that bit eric brooks uh blade then
we have to combine the morbia storyline
so i think yeah down the line this is
much farther down the line we're getting
everything together but yeah they're
gonna come in together i agree with all
of you all of you first time
and i think i think one of the biggest
things also to keep in mind is is this
going to be a profitable venture for
marvel i know the regular answer the
more common answer is yes but then you
have a lot of people who are used to the
whole super powered humans things of
that sort not a lot of people know that
side of marvel and so
blade is a recognizable name because of
what wesley snipes in with the franchise
previous seeing the black knight is a is
a huge you know shocker to a lot of
people because not a lot of people know
about the character um so it's going to
be interesting if they
kind of start testing the waters with
this and seeing if it's going to be
something they continue i would
obviously blade is already on the on the
slate for it to be put out hopefully
sometime soon but when it comes to you
know the black knight that that may be
something they might start testing in
with like disney plus as a series or
even piecemeal it for the halloween
special that's supposed to be coming out
next year
right the the wharf the gary
bar garcia bernal uh werewolf yeah oh
yes oh beautiful i i think like marvel
should feel bullish about this because
how many people's first access point to
the mcu was simply one division like
we're all msu nerds who have been with
this franchise for years and years but
so many people were like what is this uh
elizabeth olsen yes um catherine hahn's
series on disney plus about witches this
is crazy yeah and how seamless that
transition felt when we revealed it was
agatha all along where wanda goes into
the satanic dungeon and then the next
episode begins with a prologue flashback
of a satanic witch trial uh of a bunch
of witches and a coven chanting latin
phrases and like i was so pumped like
that this is part of the mcu now and it
just felt like it was part of the mcu
from the beginning it felt so natural so
i think the fact that like that made
sense to us from a tonal perspective
shows that the sky's the limit or the
reaches of hell are the limit to be more
accurate when it comes to things like
mephisto and moon knight and blade and
the midnight suns
give us more of it like i think general
audiences are totally ready for this and
totally ready to explore that and let's
be clear here leading the tale of this
team needs to be ghost rider oh yeah for
sure absolutely
is 100 going to be on this uh blade team
that is being assembled he's got to be
it's gonna be ghost rider moon knight um
black knight um but what else who else i
was just thinking about something the
green knight the green night the green
knight everybody loves that martin
lawrence two black knights
get out get out show them the door but
no but no on a more serious note i i
like the fact that uh how eric brought
up one division because i think that one
division in particular the dark hold is
going to be a huge part of what's going
on moving forward because the dark hold
is this super old book that you know
makes people like agatha crazy like it
it sort of manipulates your you know
mind and makes you you know do dark
magic stuff so like who knows how many
people throughout the course of human
history have been affected by this dark
hold how many you know uh monsters that
are out there um and like now that the
mcu is going into this interdimensional
route i think that in the mcu all of
these you know vampires and you know
mystical stuff are going to have an
interdimensional source especially with
the uh the sword itself the ebony blade
when it speaks to dane whitman we're
going it's going to be probably revealed
that's going to be like that whole shang
chi like who who's talking to me oh it's
it's a being from beyond and the source
what does that do oh it's the plane it's
the blade i mean it's the ghostbusters
looking at a scenario where this may be
the first time a scene has come up in
the mcu in 2021 where a voice a demonic
voice came from some object and i did
not say it was mephisto
like is it gonna be like this voice is
the first time i didn't say hey that's
my stuff i mean that ends up being the
case that still seems plausible i mean
hey
you know
that there like we said marvel's great
at retooling things who knows
uh i might be
i might be a little off i'll be honest
um black knight isn't a big part of my
repertoire but is it
his blade is the ebony blade i feel like
this is a stretch this is a stretch this
is a stretch but if we wanted to tie
um blade to the ebony blade could is
there a way that his soul could be
connected to the ebony blade like could
he have been slain by the ebony blade or
something stabbed by anything what have
you because there has to be a reason i
don't think he's actually in that room
with him at the end it's clearly sounded
disembodied that's why i'm like it's in
the blade
he's opening the box the blade or the
box is talking one of the two i mean i
don't know if it's in the blade but like
i think the blade itself is just cursed
right that's what we know about the
ebony blade it does have some kind of
evil to it so i think that was talking
to him but i i think you are right
jessica i don't think blade physically
is standing in the room in that scene i
think he is
channeling him through some kind of dark
magic in this movie because why would
they why would they edit mahershala's
voice to sound echoey like that it could
be his family's lawn my room wasn't big
enough for that kind of echo
and everybody knows that eddie is an
architect so
eddie knows that surround sounds i think
eddie monster's waiting to happen it's
like we just go back to an actual room
if you look at the cubic feet from the
top of that floor to the bottom
right there it's just mahershala's
standing next to one of those old horns
are you sure you're ready for that mr
whitman the ebony blade's so old and if
it has been passed down through his
family there could have been a time that
i know this sounds like a freaking old
like dracula series but his family could
have worked with blade potentially at
one point if you take the storyline his
uncle i believe is the one who ends up
being immensely cursed by the blade to
the point to where he goes crazy he
turns evil and
there i mean they could retcon this
entire story where blade at one point in
time was the one who had to put him down
or you know was a part of that battle
and in the middle killed uncle nathan
yeah and and maybe in the process of it
got struck or hit by the blade and has a
part of that curse which is why there's
like maybe this telepathic connection
between him and that blade in order for
him to speak to
dan whitman all right eddie you get
a golden rogi for that theory a golden
rule great theory on that one
uh
jessica i'm gonna give you a golden rogi
because i think it's rogue you said it
was a stretch but i like it uh i'm gonna
give you a point for this idea that like
blade could be mystically connected to
the ebony blade and that was a little
word play implied by the subtext of the
scene but there's a literal meaning to
it as well mt i'm gonna give you uh two
points uh for being uh the first one to
cite mephisto in this episode uh that's
a shortcut you cashed it on it and it
worked
you found the secret code
you tell us not to bring it up uh and
i'm gonna give you a second one for that
too that's how much i want mephisto
he figured out the code well we have
some uh more about the andy minutes of
eternals we want to talk about but uh
first there's a brand new latest
obsession shirt inspired by marvel's
eternals available at
newrockstarsmerch.com
these are limited edition shirts and
once they sell out they are retired to
the blue dundin with me
where i uh use them to just pad my chair
for my tough little tush tush so you
should grab one of these shirts as soon
as possible i thought you were sitting a
little higher yeah
shirt i just yep uh uh so find these
shirts and all the great merch options
at new rockstarsmerch.com also i
recently got some socks from one of the
sponsors of this episode stance and they
are both incredibly comfortable but also
very well designed they feel great and
they're just kind of funky and looks not
in smell and founded in 2009 stance
apparel has reinvented socks t-shirts
and more they have a sharp focus on
comfort quality and creativity stance
brings an atypical aesthetic alongside
some of pop culture's hottest
collaborators for the ultimate in style
and self-expression because everything
you wear should be a direct extension of
who you are and how you feel they do a
lot of stylish collaborations with
brands that you love they currently have
sock collaborations with batman pixar
star wars and a bunch of cool designers
and artists i might need to grab some of
their marvel designs i know they'll be
incredibly comfortable and they just
look really cool the stance philosophy
is that a perfect fit is more important
than simply fitting in that those who
feel good do good go see for yourself
just head on over to stance.com and pick
out whatever styles you like enjoy the
color and comfort of a life less
ordinary with stance also if you dread
looking at your credit card statements
you're not alone the weight of debt can
feel crippling but upstart can help you
on your path to financial freedom
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used up start to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smarter rate for your loan you can
check your rate without impacting your
credit score in minutes for loans
between one thousand and fifty thousand
dollars you can ever you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com rogue that's upstart.com
rogue don't forget to use our url to let
them know that we sent you loan amount
to be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
upstart.com
rogue also the weather is getting colder
and all of our clothing choices are
leaning cozier and comfortable whether
you're apple picking sitting by a
campfire or just running into the
grocery store faraday is here to help
with the perfect clothes for getting
comfy when you want the best quality
clothes you call in the troops you know
when you're searching for that ideal
cozy outfit that shirt that sweater the
ones that feel like you've had them for
years with the perfect prints that fit
so perfectly and feel almost too good to
be vintage but look like they still
might be well that's parody they are so
confident in the quality of their stuff
they have a lifetime guarantee they'll
replace or fix your clothes forever no
matter what and to top it all off
faraday is giving the rogue theory
audience 20 off 20
off so stock up on all your fall and
winter clothes now head on over to
faritybrand.com and enter the promo code
rogue at checkout to snag 20 off all
your gear that's verity f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand.com and promo code rogue for 20
off your fairty purchase all right
getting back to eternals folks uh how
will cersei be rescued from airship and
the other celestials because this
eternal mid-credit scene suggested eros
the eternal of titan and his own
celestial connection that allowed him to
locate cersei and save her from
erisham's judgment might be the way
cersei and her friends get rescued will
gore the god butcher's war path against
the celestials and thor love and thunder
helps cersei break free will icarus pop
out of the other side of the sun with
new powers that allow him to free cersei
did eros hook up with adam warlock at
some point in the past
will cersei's fate be explored in
guardians volume three thor love and
thunder or is marvel just planning on
making us forget about this loosen with
lots of other big plot threads in the
near future what do you guys think you
know i like to believe that last one all
the time
that's what i normally lean towards
marvel's just
but um i think the whole arrows thing is
going to lean more towards them the just
like running into the guardians and adam
warlock in um the next guardians movie
what i think what will happen for cersei
i don't think she's going to be rescued
this is the rogue this is maybe the
rogues theory i've ever said because i
love the internals and celestials
i think cersei's going to become a
celestial
oh
i think so i think she the fact of like
the in the movie that she can turn i
with the help of other ones which is why
he stole all of them from the planet the
fact that she can turn a celestial to
stone
is so incred it's so crazy that i think
it's gonna be air shims gonna be like
you're a little too wild to be an
eternal we're gonna just make you a
celestial we're gonna combine the other
ones that we took from earth because he
thinks he just took all of them from
earth he doesn't know that sprite's a
human spoiler he doesn't know that
sprite's a human he doesn't know that
the other three are out in space so he
thought he took them all and he's just
gonna combine them into cersei's and
she's gonna become a celestial and i
think she's gonna wipe he's gonna reboot
her mind where she's we're gonna see
that cersei we're gonna see that gemma
chan but where she's gonna be just a
celestial and then arrows is gonna come
back because arrows is not going to be
dead he's not going to be dead by the
sun and he's going to try to like get
her back but she's like i'm the gaudiest
of gods so i think i think my rope there
is she's she's not going to be rescued
she doesn't need to be rescued because
she's going to be a celestial i love it
yeah yeah yeah that's really good we're
gonna reframe the argument here jessica
these female eternals don't always need
rescuing right they can solve their own
problems thank you very much
thank you
well on a chauvinistic site
no
i i feel like
oh my god jess that was great um i feel
like for everything going on with what
we have going on in the mcu i feel like
with the connection between nebula and
gamora with eros arrows being uh
thanos's brother i feel like we're gonna
get to see them again in the next
guardians of the galaxy film um i feel
like that's gonna be a part of if not a
part of a a small leg of that particular
storyline in terms of clarification
because
knowing that in the comic books
obviously going back to that you know at
one point in time we actually see and i
don't know if this is something they're
going to do in the future but we
actually see where thanos actually is
resurrected in the body of eros
and
knowing that that's something that could
possibly come back because i mean let's
face it josh bullon was amazing as
thanos that was a great character i
don't think we were going to see the end
of that at all and i feel like
gamora and nebula are going to be aware
that thanos has that ability
and they're going to kind of be on this
you know really suspect mindset if when
they see eros recognizing him as the
brother of thanos um they're gonna see
him and they're gonna essentially
not just try to decide whether to kill
him or not kill him um
all the while the he's gonna be with the
eternals trying to rescue cersei and the
other eternals um i i just i really feel
like this is something that they have to
really respond to in terms of uh the
information that they've given because
if not like you said it's it's going to
be one of those loose ends that probably
won't get tied up until further down the
road and people may actually forget
about it and i hope people don't other
than the fact that harry styles is
heiress eros not many other people are
gonna realize you know the enormity of
that character i mean he even has a huge
uh
uh a huge spot to play in the whole
infinity gauntlet storyline
um
and
his recognition there and and
i just really hope they they do
something quick and i'm hoping it's in
the guardians of the galaxy uh next film
because that seems to make the most
sense to me i like that i think that's a
lot of good points i love that you
brought up this idea of uh of thanos
being resurrected in aeros's form i
think that is like a point a lot of
people are missing about their history
in the comics and uh for thanos to come
back in that way i just think is
incredible i think i think people are
agreeing with eddie i think people are
under
like playing or not well maybe i think
we were underplaying star fox
introduction i don't think people i
think we were over selling like oh it's
harry styles we get that but star fox is
a really big deal um especially in the
comics star fox has like such a horrible
background um so i think when i first
saw it my first imagination of it was
like oh he's on the run it's not that he
they found him that he's just like in
trouble and he's trying to jump on the
first ship out of anywhere because star
fox is such a problematic person so yeah
uh but i agree i was like
starfix is insane yeah i really truly
hope that marvel ends up making star fox
the new star lord after guardians 3
because it just makes sense like he's so
he's so much like star lord he's a
player and he's like a star team person
he has to be in james gunn's movie he
has to be in james yeah
oh my god play would be so fun for him
okay keep going yeah
but by the way by the way really quick
sorry is anybody is anybody else excited
the fact that they're bringing pat and
oswalt into the mcu patent oswald
and um
and he was in agents of shield yeah but
now he's like officially mcu cannon and
he was in blade trinity
that's right that's right
i just hope they give him better vfx
next time we see pip because that was
kind of like that was like
playstation one cutscene almost a little
bit yeah but anyway no uh i think for me
um to go kind of roguish here we have to
remember that druid is on this ship um
with theena and um makari so ian druid
is you know historically a marvel
villain and like i feel like marvel's
sort of like introducing druid as you
know as the sympathetic you know very
um empathetic person towards humanity
which he is but then when i feel like
when he meets up with the celestials
we're at you know the world forge or
wherever they're going um he's going to
use his mind control powers and he's
going to make all the celestials
uh commit celestial suicide um because
the celestial is not
going to be around forever i am very
confident you think he has the power to
like because he needed help yeah i don't
think he has the power yet but whenever
he goes to the celestial home base he's
probably going to find a machine or
something that's going to be like powers
are amplified it's going to find a
machine
oh do you think they're going to get to
what is it forge what is it what it's
not olympia
of the world forge they're gonna get
there and then he's gonna just take all
the all the power of all the celestials
being there all the eternals being made
and just hey i mean i'd like to see that
i'd like to say
that would
just one by one they just fold over like
it i mean that'd be a truly game of
thrones like red wedding or like ari
afraid
that'd be so dangerous arya killed the
phrase that'd be so dangerous for the
world there would be no more worlds
there'd be no more worlds
exactly i think that's why we needed a
multiverse reset but like he was
actually dooming the universe by killing
all the celestials and like you know um
so i think that druid might actually be
the the secret person that's gonna
actually he's gonna save everyone but is
he really seven i don't know empty i
love the dariness of this theory i think
it is rogue and i do want to see druid
go freaking crazy with his mind control
i'm gonna award you
one point for your theory
uh eddie i think you're right i think
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 is where
this is gonna appear i really really
like your theory a lot i'm gonna give
you a point too but jessica i think
you're right on the money cersei don't
need saving you i give you two points
for your theory
[Music]
anyone's game uh before we go into rogue
questions guys there is nothing sexier
than confidence and blue chew can help
give you some confidence where it counts
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
a chewable tablet and at a fraction of
the cost you can take these anytime day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready for whenever an opportunity arises
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive a
prescription within days for the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting line the
pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discrete package so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and we've got a
special deal for our audience try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code rogue checkout just pay the five
dollars in shipping that's bluechu.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month for free visit bluechew.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this show all right we have
arrived at our rogue question here is
our question for this week paul rudd was
named people magazine sexiest man alive
for 2021.
good for you paul um
you've had the same appearance for 20
years and finally people magazine came
around to award you
this award but i want to know from you
guys what would the other avengers say
when they found out that scott lang
among them
out sexied them i feel like hulk would
say puny sexy guy
and then pull his pants down and be like
what about there you go
blue and he goes blue
i think um
thor would pick up the magazine and go
this is a joke this is a mistake right i
don't i don't understand uh well what
does this paper weight have to say about
anything uh he would throw it and then
just be like um i i'm the sexiest man
alive i feel like he would take photos
of himself and keep bringing it up to
people throughout the entire movie
whatever movie it is and be like am i
sexier than him just like he's showing
his selfies to people like look look
like swiping through his pictures did
you see in the um and the ghostbusters
where you had the head shots of him
playing
he just has those head shots and he
keeps showing him the people he's like
i'm the sexiest avenger
um i think rhodey would just be like oh
little dude's big now all right little
dude's big now i i see you i see you
oh cause you said that yeah
that'd be nice he'd be like uh boost him
up what a nice thing for rodie to say
that's great uh well i'm gonna give the
point to eddie here uh because i think
that i think hulk would be offended as
smart
i think he would take the most offense
to it so that makes it a deadlock tie
for my three favorite people for this
week on rogue theory
and i'm just proud of all of you i think
you're all geniuses and poets
and i love you all and i think you did a
great job this week uh made me laugh
made me think made me fear for what
comes ahead in the mcu
from the midnight suns and ghost rider
and mephisto uh but that is it for this
episode of rogue theory i want to thank
all of our guests jessica clemons eddie
villanueva and mt uh follow all three of
them on social media follow their many
uh amazing endeavors and all the cool
stuff that they are making currently you
can support our channel by checking out
all of our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com and fun
announcement here uh if you want to talk
more about this episode of rogue theory
well our new rockstars discord server is
now open to the public we have made some
channels available to non-patrons so if
you've been supporting us on patreon we
uh we we appreciate all of your generous
support uh but now discord is just gonna
be open um some of the channels to the
general public and you can be part of
that broader community of newaxers fans
on discord if you're over 18 and you're
interested check out discord go to the
discord website and you can search new
rockstars we're we're searchable we're
findable and you can join our
conversation there follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars on all social
platforms and be sure to subscribe to
our channel here on youtube see you next
time everybody bye-bye
see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you